so we had a question on we will use it
to explain more to you from Five Points
of
the tactics involved in Ikea's growth
okay
so you have what we would do as chemo
and it kind of misleads you
if you make the mistake that that's how
the technique shows up tastic that's a
kihon Wasa okay it's like a coded
message for all kinds of things
um but it's taxable application is not
a one-to-one code you gotta look deeper
than that okay
um
so where does it show up uh we'll do it
first from
uh real estate Duty okay so let's say
I'm going to throw into the front
kazushi the front inward kazushi okay
and the guy
really hangs on to his balance okay now
stay there
the the energy of the throw is going
this way
okay
and what ends up happening and we not
only does his body
uh is going to spin on that centrifugal
energy
but just his body alone the way that his
mass is set up if he takes that hand off
the ground uh don't try not to roll try
to stay in place and leave your leg high
and you'll see don't follow what you'll
see that that leg is gonna is gonna
start to eventually spin out if you need
to use me for some base but don't hold
on yeah you see that leg starts to go
that way okay and you can run that
experiment on your own you just you just
gets here and eventually that leg will
go down to the outside okay the way your
your mask is is in relation to its line
of gravity okay so uh a guy that is
trying to pull eventually that leg will
go out and it's gonna be kind of hard uh
to demonstrate but let's see what
happens in there so trying to resist to
throw as much as off that step okay
again
okay that's fine if you fall you fall
a little spin that he's doing you guys
see that okay
uh so imagine we'll slow down and we'll
start to see that so that when that leg
is gonna get around
so yeah it'll be like that okay it's not
going to be
in the front inward kazishi so I'll show
you if you pay attention it's going to
be on the back side
of that leg okay you understand and all
you got to do is Chuck someone and there
it is every time so it's where for
example
we're in that same place okay
um
huh
all right let's let's get there all
right
I don't understand let's look at it just
G uh geometrically so uh the guys coming
in and then we're trying for that and
then what he does is he goes ahead and
sacrifices this balance position okay he
in essence he's going with the energy
you see that's what he's doing and so if
you look for uh where it tends to come
off is uh you were trying to do a
momentum throw
and the guy does not fall off they
regain their balance okay and you you
held on to their arm or something like
that so if you pay attention like in in
this version we come around here
he's doing the same thing
you're in that key moment okay or even
in the basic he hon when when you come
around like that right uh from where I'm
at he's it say then his stance is in
that same thing that leg is behind the
front leg and you see the sweep is
stay home
that leg is it that back leg is in front
of his leg
can you see that
can you see it all right okay but as
soon as I go like that there it is
so I'll show just to show you uh I'm
gonna move that leg back
okay and I slide them around and I
thought behind them do you see it moved
that way the keyhole is is doing that
same thing right from where I'm at
but what you want to know is when you're
doing front inward kazuki's a guy can
sacrifice
his orientation towards you and put get
that foot there
okay you got it and it will come up more
than not in live situations where you
did a momentum from okay the way you get
out of it in your is with your cookie
projection that foot does not get to
stay there you see that but in a
momentum throat you go to do it and he
can do it
okay
in the projection throw that foot does
not
and that's why he can't counter that
throw okay but it happens a lot in live
situations uh especially if you don't
have the projection skills okay so uh
we're going here we'll do that momentum
throw and that's where it is
okay that's where your shimogan is
there's something to note though
uh in the keyhon
he's allowed to stay straight you see he
even if he turns a little he's pretty up
um back here so we can keep the
orientation
if this stuff the more he tries to stay
up uh the harder he it would be able for
him to do that
it's because this hand tends to cut down
so you're going and you're going to see
that his head is down when he does that
you see now it makes no sense and this
is the second thing it makes no sense to
bring them back up
okay
so we'll do the keyhon
and I'm going to set up that stance
there it is okay
and in the keyhorn you kind of do bring
him up
but we want to pay attention to
something in the keyhon that helps
a little bit more
okay I am going to not
turn
I'm going to come across
I'll do those two versions
okay
I'll just keep it with the motel so mote
I go in then I turn
and then I enter again
when I want you to understand
is where
I keep my Center this way I step across
there it is
same beginning but I step across there
it is
there's no turn can you see that I'll do
the other one
enter turn there's none of that
in case I have in front of you boom it's
right there
okay let's get there so we have all
those other videos I'm not gonna go into
the like the grip game okay I'll just
quickly say here Yoshino Naga is not on
the forearm it doesn't work because you
do not have the mechanical advantage
don't hurt me uh he has the mechanical
advantage okay
um he can just pull down on his elbow
and I can never hold that okay but once
I get to the wrist do you see and I turn
that more and now he does not have a
mechanical advantage because the smaller
joint is working against him so uh if we
you could even have them higher as he
tries to pull his elbow it makes his
balance go because it goes into his
wrist so you cannot do it here you
should never do it here this is you're
you're fooling yourself okay I don't
care how high it is put your elbow
really high it's you don't have the
leverager he's basically doing a thumb
lock on you which is why in similar
situations in your nawaza this would be
thumbless grip so you don't expose the
thumb to it okay
um
going on
why
don't we want him standing like that
you see this is upright or I get in
slightly tilted and then I come around
and he stands up again there do you see
do you see that okay
um well let's go back to where it tends
to open up you tried the front inward
because you see is not in that position
and two
anytime
uh your guy is standing up for any
joints any joint lock so let's do Nico
because everyone loves Nico do you think
and every you usually in Aikido they'll
show this to new people to convince them
how Marshall the art is
because they'll go like this
ah and because they're egocentric it
hurt me and I'm the center of the
universe your art must be real okay
that's all
the lock is functioning because
did not move their feet
no one told them not here but they just
don't okay any joint manipulation
requires that force be stabilized
otherwise
the articulatable
[Music]
joints
will take away your leverage okay so for
example if I leave my feet here and he
does the lock it's gonna work okay if I
move my feet it does not work now it's
off do it do you see and he would have
to turn to put it back on
he'll put it back on you see
but what can I do so he tries to put it
on I change the joint manipulation the
the angles of the articulation he moves
and I moved
they're saying it'll never stop you get
that so your techniques have ways of
stopping them
and the way in
is their body is trapped within an
inertial path you can't reverse it do
you get that okay so
the only way I keep them tracking the
inertial path is not let them Bop off
that's taking them out of the inertial
path and now he has full mobility and
the joint The Joint lock or the joint
manipulation will not work so we go and
as long as I keep my feet here go and he
does she who knock it it is going to
work that leverage thing that I just
told you is going to work okay
but if I move my feet
even when he's here you see and I moved
to here it's not going to work now so
even that handle hand leverage thing
right if I just keep moving my feet it
won't work
so my body has to be preoccupied
and it can't be straight up because then
it is Back in Balance it now has
Mobility do you get that and the
resisting person will not be there okay
so
when you come into this technique this
little tilt that I have in the keyhorn I
am going to keep
like when you keep that tilt look try to
see where his body is
his body's going this way
okay so I'm gonna move myself
so that it will will make okay keep
going that way I'm gonna move myself so
that I catch
there okay where is there
there is that sweet spot he goes
where your compliant UK did not move
their feet do you see that if you get
shihonage and I don't move my feet he's
got you okay butterfly he doesn't have
me anymore so you have to replicate that
but now in motion so you have to kind of
think
he's going this way
he's gonna round me
so I move
so I catch him there
[Music]
and roll
another way of looking at it
he stays in that tilt
I don't stand back around
he's going to stay in the time
okay
let's try
some other things so beginner mistake is
you pick him up
beginner mistake
you're on this forearm beginner's that
doesn't work okay another beginner
mistake is uh his elbow is down
anywhere his elbow is not up okay
he has too much Leverage
I don't have any leverage even even if
I'm on the hand it's very difficult to
keep this leverage okay which is why if
he steps back
He's Able more to lower his elbow do you
see and I lose leverage as we go okay
it doesn't change if you put his elbow
here
you see you're on the side and you've
had like some kind of shoulder elbow
lock it doesn't take much for him to
pull that don't hurt me again just
put your elbow underneath you here do
you see that okay no no no
his body has to be up the elbow has to
be up which means his Center has to be
forward okay you can't get his elbow up
with his centered knot forward which
won't happen when he's straight it's
parallel pretty much and it's very easy
for him to pull down you'll lose
leverage okay
so keep that all in mind as you're doing
the this again don't have his elbow look
it's parallel can you see from behind me
or no
no is it it's petalum that's not going
to work
so his elbow is gonna go up do you see
it going up
you see that
I I have the intention
of getting his elbow to go
oh
okay
another beginner mistake is uh he's
gonna go
right and then yeah it's okay right and
then I turn I can turn like this you see
how my hips turn that way
you see that but in the technique is
which way were my hips going my hips
going this way do you understand
so usually the way that happens but you
want to pay attention to it is uh you
are not controlling their center with it
being preoccupied on our inertial path
so uh maybe on your on your keyhan
they're just standing still do you see
and then you come around like that and
now he could turn into that and he could
turn the hips into that technique and
take that front brake off or maybe you
did initially occupy their Center but
then you gave it back to him now you can
turn into it you see so
his energy is going to be preoccupied
this way which would stop it from
turning this way okay but you can do
your lock in there in a way that you
actually have a lock this is where that
wrist comes in handy where the forearm
does not okay the the wrist stops him
from turning that way do you see that it
adds it adds a kind of contagiousness to
it okay and uh the more he tries to turn
his his that way it goes into the lock
okay
so as you're coming around again another
reason not to be on the forearm because
it won't allow you to control his hips
he can turn his hips and then he'll take
your beautiful front brake box
but the bad guy will escape the bad guy
will move their feet and pull their
elbow down and continue the attack okay
so you really want to right here you're
on the wrist already you already have a
photo as you see and that stops his
wrist from turning around from turning
his Center stop to the center
that gets that leg in the box and then
this this here stops in
uh turning in here
okay so get on that risk another reason
I want to make sure that you understand
what happens if he does if he gives me
my center it's not occupied with the
inertial path going in the opposite
direction and if he does not have uh my
Center through where he's touching such
that
I'm able to turn do you see for my nice
break fall of what when I said that the
bad guy would not be there what I mean
is since I have so much control in my
Center you see I could just continue my
attack because I'm gonna neutralize all
the joint control he has because I'm
moving those joints in space you
understand okay so let's go back uh to
generating that kind of new Cami you see
and we're going to uh take a more
advantage of this tilt that he's in
we're going to even reduce it less okay
uh it doesn't matter we'll just do it
some uh throws
you know there we go
[Music]
right there
don't don't let me break your mind
[Music]
by not going up and dropping underneath
he does not come up
even more
whoa
[Music]
okay let's do it uh so now you can do it
more or less than a keyhon setting okay
so you just kind of chill out there it
is right there
[Music]
thank you
look for that that Suki that hole
this hole right here
so I'm not having to do anything
with his body
[Music]
as you guys see he's a virtually
occupied okay
all right so if I'm doing your commands
so he's got your footage and he can't
start he can't start from out there who
because he's in my kicking range you got
it so he's got to get into strike to
raise right okay so he does his thing
and here's that same
same beginning okay
so he is all I hit it oh cool he fell
but
if he's fat he gets his balance right
well there you have it right there
right
foreign
[Music]
trying to get his arm and spin him
around right uh here's the end
adhesion till I get that elbow and then
the Yoko man is going over the top you
see that
and the yoga man is not a lightsaber
man oh he is already so this stay there
all this I'll just do this put on his
elbow on my elbow on his chest it's hot
it's going to do damage
yeah so you are taking this balance
and then he counters that and that's
where your Shield will not get it
he's got to give that openly okay
try it again it's not your job to spin
him around
you see that you can't catch Stripes
like that you cannot catch the stripes
you can't block them either
you blend with the dislike your sword
work
okay let's go
okay so a question came up in our
trading and they weren't understanding
it and they went back to a goofy Aikido
culture okay so uh here we are we're
we're doing now the Striking you're
getting this kind of stuff you see and
uh the person swings around so let me
use you because just do what you do
that he comes around and the person
swings around you see and they keep
walking they keep walking around do you
understand
keep walking around me
can you just do
you're gonna do it again just walk
around me walk around me walk around
with music
that is not the opening okay that is not
the opening the opening was
on a failed Kohinoor
or any technique that is going to the
front inward kazushi pattern
okay
in order for them
to become
unprojectable they're gonna disconnect
their Center
do you understand that okay uh so
if you pay attention
and she's doing the strike
his body is nowhere as organized you see
that
now try not to fall down
you see
now it's not organized but one little
Shuffle back tiny little Shuffle
it's not organized it's twisted if you
pay attention
organize yourself again
you see now he's got a strong homologous
side to him
when he is Twisted
uh I'm not sure you even understand sir
I'm like this
you see as opposed to like this so
set it here
I'm like this
there's a Twist to my body which is what
freed me freed my center from the Coq
Nagin so lock my body he's gonna project
me but I'm going to disconnect it you
see this corner fell out right and as
this leg now is not going to come around
into pirouette
it's gonna come around boom like that
you see and I'm twisted again
that is where she would not get opening
is okay
if I do this and a person would
pirouette that's Twisted go back in a
perfect pirouette this is when you take
the box and you do something like
foreign
there it is right there
[Music]
do you have to look for that
when you have a new kid who will not
twist for you it's because you did not
do the kokunaga and they did not counter
it you did this thing
they come around perfectly
homolaterally aligned okay
so all you have to do
is
get the energy going Moon there's the
twist right there that's where I come in
okay
try it